morrison's sales are down year on year
roughly in line with the market
and it's no surprise the market's down
why not well this time last year
nobody was eating out and about in pubs
and restaurants and cafes
and all that sort of out of home sector
is slowly reopening up
so the volumes are starting to shift
away from the supermarkets
but don't think that that bubble has
burst on what has been a very
buoyant sector in the last year because
when you compare against 2019
so pre-pandemic in the latest 12 weeks
sales are actually up 3.3
billion pounds on that 2019 number so
it's still a pretty healthy place to be
it really is isn't it i mean put the
morrison's performance for me into
context fraser if you would please i
mean over the last three years there has
been a significant operational
turnaround
yeah so morrison's had a really long run
of underperforming in the market
and just over a year ago they turned
that round and ever since
have been ahead of the market every
single four weeks when we have released
these updates
now morrisons i think primarily have
been right-sized for the conditions
we've found ourselves in of covid
so the stores are not too large but
they're not too small and they're local
enough that people are still willing to
travel to them on top of that
i think they've done some really great
things over over that time as well
they're one of the few supermarkets
still pushing the multibyte promotion
that seems to have fallen out of favor
as many retailers look to move
more to an operating model like
discounters but shoppers
and some shoppers do like promotions
they do like wandering down the aisles
and be excited
and be urged to try and buy new things
and perhaps those of you will
buy those few more items in the basket
and that's where morrison's i've had a
point of difference
and many supermarkets look the same so
the point of difference is good
yeah very interesting looking at your
two-roll data today the
the other members of the big four tesco
sainsbury's and asda they have all put
on market share during the last year
yeah so they're starting to reclaim back
a little bit
of what they lost to the convenience
channel remember early lockdown last
year
people weren't really leaving the house
they were just walking to their local
local small shop and start reclaim a
little bit back from online as well
because online market share has remained
stable this month
against may so it's no longer growing at
the same rate it was
in fact year on year it's barely growing
at all so we've reached a new plateau
for online
and all that leaves space for those big
supermarkets to grow
of course most of them are growing
through their online sales that's the
main growth driver and just some of them
i managed to get more people in through
the stores
so who are these gains at the expense of
independence i presume but it also looks
like co-op struggling a bit
this is an unexpected co-op in
particular had a bumper last year
and independent stores too so i don't
think those businesses are going to be
surprised
but they will be trying to make plans to
hold on to as many of those gains as
they possibly can
and like i said previously about the
total market they are still considerably
up on two years ago
so it's not like it's a disaster for
them but the discounters have started on
that march
march back so both aldi and little the
story of the last decade really has
been then making inroads into the uk
grocery market
they started taking market share again
in fact aldi
have reached 8.2 percent of the market
which is matching their highest ever
market share
achieved in march last year so i think
that story
is going to start coming back on in the
next few months we keep hearing a lot
about some of these fast delivery
startups the likes of gettier and deeja
and weezy and so forth
are they posing any kind of threat yet
to the to the multiples
i think it's very very early days
remarkably few shoppers have actually
tried those services yet because of
course they're geographically limited
they're limited to urban areas where it
makes sense and they're probably limited
to people
who are likely to try those kind of
services which tend to be the younger
shopper
and tend to be a more affluent shopper
who's willing to pay the delivery
charges
but the market that they're going after
is huge
so over 40 billion pounds a year are
spent on grocery baskets that are less
than 25 pounds
so even if they manage to only grab a
small part of that
then that's a very large market and it's
not just the startups or the likes of
gorillas and get here and wheezy but
also
tesco getting got in on the axe now and
ocado i've had a long running service
called
zoom as well it's very interesting to
see how that's going to pan out over the
next few years